[Musik]
wenn im rheinland-pfälzischen Bad
Kreuznach Michaela Haag in Ihren Garten
tritt sieht sie seit rund einem Jahr das
eine elfeinhalb Meter hohe
Industriehalle eigentlich dürfte das
Ungetüm hier gar nicht stehen denn
Familie Haak hat gegen die
Baugenehmigung der Stadt geklagt und
gewonnen das Gericht erklärte die Halle
für illegal aber jetzt hat die
Verwaltung den Bau noch mal genehmigt
wir leben in Deutschland und es wurde
ein Urteil gesprochen und das Urteil ist
rechtskräftig und wenn sich da keiner
dran hält warum sprechen dann die
Richter urteile ich verstehe es nicht
seit 15 Jahren lebt Michaela Haag hier
in Bad Kreuznach doch im april 2021 wird
alles anders auf dem benachbarten
Firmenparkplatz wird plötzlich eine
Halle gebaut genehmigt von der Stadt
wird das Gebäude zu nah an der
Grundstücksgrenze hochgezogen egal wo
sie ist Frau Haack hat die Halle jetzt
immer vor der Nase die Familie klagt
gegen die Baugenehmigung und gewinnt den
Prozess das Verwaltungsgericht Koblenz
stellt klar beim Bau der Halle wurden
die Abstandsflächen nicht eingehalten
deshalb ist die Baugenehmigung
rechtswidrig alles gut denkste denn
jetzt hat die Stadt eine neue
Genehmigung erteilt und den Bau trotz zu
geringer Abstände ausnahmsweise
abgesegnet ja das finde ich noch eine
große Sauerei also diese Frau also diese
Familie hat gewonnen und es passiert gar
nichts also respektloses Verhalten finde
ich muss ich ehrlich sagen wie
bürgernapolitik sieht für mich ganz
anders aus auf dem Bauamt sind ja auch
Leute die irgendwo privat wohnen und
wenn dann eine Halle von 11 Meter 50
nehmen wir dran baut auf drei oder vier
Meter ich glaube nicht dass das gut
ankommt
Kreuznacher Stadtverwaltung hält die
neue Baugenehmigung für rechtens
außerdem bemühe sie sich das Wohl aller
Parteien im Auge zu behalten
gleichzeitig muss sie in Situationen in
denen mehrere Beteiligte ihre
berechtigten Interessen verfolgen
oftmals wieder streiten Interessen in
Ausgleich bringen der Rechtsanwalt von
Familie Haag sieht deren Interessen
überhaupt nicht berücksichtigt das
Vorgehen der Stadt verschiebt
letztendlich die Verantwortlichkeiten
hin zur Familie Haag die letztendlich
dafür bestraft wird aus meiner Sicht
dass sie sich gegen so ein Vorhaben Wert
und das finde ich nicht richtig also wir
werden da wirklich richtig reingezwungen
wir wollten das hier alles ja gar nicht
wir haben das Ding hier nicht eingebaut
Michaela Haag wird auch die neue
Baugenehmigung nicht akzeptieren jetzt
muss wieder ein Gericht entscheiden ob
man ihr einfach so diese monsterhalle
vor die Nase setzen darf